knocking story of media depravity on a
most solemn day for this country an
op-ed for the Washington Post shows that
MSNBC's Joe Scarborough complaining that
the president is a greater danger to the
United States than foreign terrorists
something he expanded on this morning if
you strip America of its ideas forget
about knocking down buildings in the
financial district forget about running
planes into the Pentagon those are
tragedies but those tragedies bring us
closer together
America is an idea you got America of
that idea mm-hmm that's when you do the
most harm to America this is seems to me
a far graver graver threat to the idea
of America Peter respond is New York
Fire Department's commissioner during
9/11 Thomas von essen Tom first of all
it's a solemn day for all of the
firefighters in New York and across this
country police first responders all the
victims and their families thank you for
your service to New York all those years
and especially on 9/11 I had to get your
thoughts on this Joe Scarborough saying
the president is more dangerous to
America than the 9/11 terrorists it's
even worse when you hear him say it it's
pretty upsetting being at the ceremony
this morning and it was one of the
family members got up and he was begging
politicians and the press to stop
politicizing September 11 to stop using
the families as fodder for you know
opinions on one side or the other
these are folks that mostly all of them
actually innocent people on on airplanes
or in buildings or firefighters police
officers and emergency first responders
who just tried to go in and make a
difference in and help people and get
them out of harm's way
I've known at least I would say between
five to ten of the firefighters good
friends of mine whose kids grew up and
went to military academies or with the
idea of going in the military serving
the country serving to honor their
fathers and most of those fathers were
really special guys the best of the best
we had and we had some really great
people so I would really doubt that if
you asked any of those kids graduating
from Naval Academy at West Point well
the kids that went on the job to honor
their parents that fathers how they felt
about it the police officers and the
firefighters I think you might get a
very different version of the politics
of dissing agreeing with the president
who we should be working to help no
matter what our opinions off and
comparing them to a grave threat from a
foreign nation yeah it's easy to make
these comments from a comfy studio in
Manhattan I guess but I don't know I
just kept thinking of the you know that
day and what we were seeing on the
ground and all the firefighters who
walked up when everyone else is walking
down those buildings shaking and falling
senator angus King in Maine he compared
a Russian election meddling Tom with
9/11 let's watch
[Music]
[Music]
so Russian election meddling serious but
it's basically the same kind of attack
as 9/11 I know I don't even know what to
say that these people at this point but
I'm wanting your opinion no I mean there
is no comparison and I don't know how
reasonable people if they were just
thinking about the folks that were
involved the firefighters involved the
civilians involved people who worked at
Wall Street people whose wives went to
work that day people whose sons and
daughters went to work and and we were
lost because of some evil sick people
that decided to hurt a country that they
hated so much a civilization that they
hated so much a way of life that they
hated so much and if these politicians
would do their job that they swore to
swore to do we wouldn't have half of
these issues that we have I don't know
how they take paychecks and go home
every night I don't understand how
somebody takes an oath and just doesn't
do that job that doesn't have what
firefighters and police officers and
soldiers if you don't do your job as a
soldier you pay a price with these
politicians they're not doing their job
they haven't done their job and far as
immigration or any these issues for 20
25 years so I'm not really too hopeful
on them doing it now and Tom I just
can't believe we're still debating
whether the country needs to have a
secure border all these years I'm not
just talking about Trump Obama Bush all
these years we still don't have a secure
border I mean with thousands of people
crossing the border and and it is a
security threat it is a security threat
Tom thank you so much it's great to see
you tonight and our prayers are always
with New York
Shanksville in Washington DC thank you
so much